[Music]  you got to work with Pacino that you  know the whole it's a bit iconic now I  guess and look great ah Michael Mann who  directed that does a lot it takes much  like the great Jim Brooks a lot of takes  and you get a little lost in it on take  whatever seventy it was al finally  probably out of boredom but just wanted  to switch it up just scream that he had  been doing the line you know because she  got a great ass you've been doing it  like that and then all the sudden  exploded out of them and if you look in  the movie my reaction I'm not acting I  got genuinely terrified money yelled up  great anti great yeah exactly there  there it is  and if you keep like you hear me go  Jesus